here are some celebrity moments from
right before the pandemic that you
probably forgot about just one month
before the pandemic hit JLo and Shakira
played their iconic Super Bowl halftime
show little did we know we'd all be
quarantining a month later speaking of
JLo she was still with aerod at the time
yeah the pandemic changed all that Megan
Fox was also still with Brian Austin
Green you know before the mgkification
of it all and Lana Del Rey was dating a
cop and she wore a dress from Dillards
to the Grammys iconic everybody got
obsessed with the viral shallow Subway
singer Charlotte Aubry no idea where she
is now but glad she got her moment
megsit happened right before the end of
February ultimately leading to the tulja
discourse and lastly before the pandemic
Nick Cannon only had three kids now he
is 12.